the number-two official of the Justice
Department is playing hardball with
congressional Republicans who are
investigating the Russia collusion Pro
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge is in Washington
tonight to tell us about it hello
Catherine
thank you Chris the emails review by Fox
News were sent to the House Office of
General Counsel to document the January
closed two-hour meeting that included
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
FBI director Christopher ray
their senior advisors as well as the
Republican House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez and his senior
staff the account claimed Rosenstein
threatened to turn the tables on the
committee regarding the Russia probe
quote the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein criticized the committee for
sending our requests in writing and was
further critical of the committee's
request to have DOJ FBI do the same when
responding committee investigator cash
patel wrote going so far as to say that
if the committee likes being litigators
then we the Justice Department to our
litigators and we will subpoena your
records and your emails referring to the
house committee and Congress over all
the emails reviewed by Fox News indicate
a second committee staffer at the
meeting backed up the account writing
quote let me just add that watching the
Deputy Attorney General launch a
sustained personal attack against a
congressional staffer in retaliation for
vigorous oversight was astonishing and
disheartening also having the nation's
number-one for these matters law
enforcement officer threatened to
subpoena your calls and your emails was
downright chilly but the FBI Justice
Department disputed the characterization
adjusted Department official told Fox
News Rosenstein never threatened a
criminal investigation writing the
Deputy Attorney General was making the
point after being threatened with
contempt that as an American citizen
charged with the offense of contempt of
Congress he would have the right to
defend himself including requesting
production of relevant emails and text
messages and calling them as witnesses
to demonstrate that their allegations
are false the official went further
saying the Deputy Attorney General quote
will further request the house general
counsel conduct an internal
investigation of these congressional
staffers conduct adding chairman Nunez
did not complain after the meeting at a
dinner with Rosen Stein and a mutual
friend in a statement of Fox News Nunez
said they take staff concerns seriously
and referred the matter to the speaker's
office a source close to the speaker
said they have encouraged the committee
to work through the Justice Department's
inspector general's office
Justice Department officials said no
formal complaint has been filed at this
time Chris Catherine thank you welcome